all
right the next
presentation is with Pablo Fernandez
maiera so welcome back
Pablo
hello back here okay exited take us on
an adventure of
curiosity yes I'm GNA start sharing my
screen let me know if everything is all
right
uh should be
perfect yep
cool so this is one of my favorite memes
and
um and probably most of you know it uh
this reference uh is um um the cave of
platon and
uh to me it was kind of fine to
truth that uh now with active inference
seems like we are closer to demonstrate
that that how it
is
so um the first time that I start uh act
in and
serve at The Institute uh I just uh this
was my kind of my feeling or my face uh
was uh looking into something that it
was complex
scary and look interesting so I went and
why I decided to to go through it
um uh I Envision a world where people is
driving by strong incentives that
motivate them to reduce uncertainty uh
in the systems they are part of and uh
my Approach is through games which are
going to go later but I really on this
talk want to encourage uh all kinds of
persons or people that are curious and I
want them to um act and get involved in
the community because you may find that
uh uh for now um most of the uh actors
are uh scientists and very well and
reputated people and you might think
that you are
not uh a part of of it but uh very far
away from that uh The Institute
encourage uh the opposite so I'm super
glad to have been through this journey
and I wanted to share a little bit of my
background and then we go to the game
um here is the second and last meme uh
the world you were rais uh to survive is
not longer exist we are on a digital
Revolution and with this digital
Revolution uh it comes bunch of
different um things that are evolving
and hopefully uh bring us to a better
world um okay who I am I'm Pablo my name
is Pablo but uh um more defined or well
much what best Define me is my action
and my
experiences
um
um I think uh role game plays and sports
and movies are super important and as a
kid I was uh uh dyslexic and the system
didn't F my necessities so I really
hated a school but I love learning and
it's something that I've been doing all
my life and it's curious how uh A system
that is designed to uh give you
knowledge and
to uh uh help you with the learning in
my case it didn't work at all and and
just that's a little uh starting point
uh uh I believe in in the copy
transformation and combine of things and
on my uh
adulthood uh everything uh sifted and I
became uh successful uh professional and
I love um it teams um um um what I do
for living is uh a product manager and
what I do on my pet projects site
projects call it as you want uh is
related to uh gaming and gamifying um uh
organizations and
experiences um uh nowadays I trust more
my intuition which is something that uh
it really was broken during my childhood
and you will see a little bit more about
that here are some things of my interest
uh licenses uh like open science which
is the case of the Institute philosophy
and that's the first meme education
governance family
art um love communication
technology and nature and a bunch of
other things that I would be happy to
share any other
time and one of the questions that
Daniel asked me for this talk is it was
what was exciting for me uh about all
this what right and for me I always when
when I I give talks I I like to
share a view of the last 100 years and
and and the Industrial Revolution and
how uh the the ones that were on this
world uh before us did something right
I'm sure that we all know uh big um
mistake or big things that have fail or
that could be uh better through
iterations but um data it's it's very uh
promising and and very good I I think is
um inspiring to have uh this the basic
education how it grows uh the
vaccination what it dids did for us uh
democracy and how poverty drop drugly
how
literate it it grew and because all this
uh things uh child
mortality uh just went very
low um so basically the future of
education is what makes me be
excited
and how I ended on this ecosystem uh
it's super a random and I'm G to explain
it in hopefully two to five minutes I um
as a product manager and very interested
on technology I heard about blockchains
back in 2015 and I didn't understood
anything at all and then back in
2017 I heard about hos I didn't start
them did not play that game but uh it
was uh rasing a fun thing to consider
which is digital assets and ownership of
those digital assets uh uh for now we we
we didn't have a a technology that could
scale and that was uh good enough to
ensure that the digital assets that you
own uh where you yours and you had the
fre freom of
transaction uh on them I I did
understand that very fast and because
I'm a game player and as a game player
you always have your different assets
and and do things with them and as well
I I I have been uh collecting music uh
and all kind of uh digital um assets uh
I bought uh this very famous collection
of uh punks and sold them very fast
before uh I Could Be A
Millionaire but due in 2021 I decided
that I wanted to build something and
then uh back then I went through this uh
beautiful project that was the first art
so on ethereum which one of the artist
it was Daniel uh fredman so I as a
curious person and a person that has
been working with artists I always like
to know what is the driver of those
artists uh what they do and and try to
get in their worlds to understand better
and to get as much information as as I
can uh before I decide to uh encourage
or collect or or or just deep deep
always uh deeper on on music or art for
me is um very nice nice thing to do so I
discover uh these cards and
education um was one of them and I went
through uh flicker which is where it was
the first at least what that I found uh
place what it was and the license it was
a creative common license uh of not
commercial use but uh it it was an open
license which I've been uh a part of
creative common Community for a very
very very long time since I was uh uh
working with musicians and I think is
one of the best things that happened to
the
internet um this is these are some of
the pragmatic uh uh things that uh the
audience cares cares about hopefully we
will have some of these on or games uh
AI for sure is going to be there um free
energy principle is going to be one of
the things that hopefully
we help to minimize and to make it
funnier games or happier games or and
games that help organizations to be
better uh the human factor uh it's super
important for me and implementation an
action I learned by doing and it's one
of the values that uh The Institute
encourage more so uh I just jump on
things and try to understand them
through doing and sharing as I'm doing
now uh here are the epistemics and um
Collective uh is one of them that I'm as
well uh super
interest um agents of course
uh practical and curiosity which is the
adventure that I'm uh I have the feeling
that I'm being involved all my my life
and that I encourage always
my my two girls to to be curious and to
uh open things and look behind the doors
and just be anactive
here are some values that I'd like to
point which are exploration uh the
culture of curiosity that I did mention
a lot um uh continuous learning uh
because that experience on the school I
think I I just keep going and keep going
and it's something that sometimes um um
bad experiences could turn out in good
habits uh learning by doing as I already
told
and integrity and inclusivity
honesty account accountability a big one
um trying to be professional on
everything that you do um for me all
started as a human being
curious um people of all backgrounds and
perspectives are welcome to
the to the Institute um I could I would
be very happy to be the link and to
speak with uh uh someone that has doubts
or if I can help I think I could help on
the very early stage and and if you're
not very technical person I think I
could help there and and yeah and as we
are learning by doing I would love to
everyone uh that's uh that's on the
stream uh I'm going to search this link
which is
uh a new a new game that we are testing
and I'm excited to to share it with with
you uh it's the adventure of curiosity
and here Daniel I'm
gonna copy and paste the
link uh it would be awesome okay there's
a tiny typo on your slides it just ends
with a curiosity
okay thank you but I'm gonna I'm gonna
paste I'm gonna paste it into the
YouTube live
chat okay thank you uh yeah I told you
I'm I'm a dyslexic I have all kind of
Tyles around my life sorry for that I
always try to improve it uh let's
um okay so you sure down yeah I put it
in the YouTube chat so people can head
over there all right yeah could you tell
us about this PL form and this is the
first active
game yes um we uh started thinking on
how to do a game a while ago and we
decided to
go with this
um uh picture that explains how it works
actually it's simple and you have uh
four pieces the internal States external
States and in the middle you have the
sensory State and the active state
so here is the mission you have some
instructions that uh you can read and
would be fun if you go through them and
you can go either way and here we are
going to go to the sensory state where
you're going to listen to a
music where some
notes you
can censor that are not in the famous
song of for
Elise
so you have to take
notes
and you can
go and you can see that we are on the
mark of blanket which so everything very
delini as Del would paint
it and here is your active uh part of
the game where you have to do something
which
is add the different notes
that your uh Professor
music Professor is telling you don't
miss because you probably on the
uh external uh state are trying to play
the music so you have to infer that you
are missing some
notes
and
go
to the active
State and start uh walking through the
right note uh if I miss the
note I just follow fall into the nothing
and come back it into my internal state
so uh probably would have to go back and
sensor
again and once I take the right actions
and the right notes I can go and solve
the puel and the idea here is to have a
tool gaming tool to um explain or so you
can uh
experience
how this uh active inference on free
energy
works and once
you go to the end
of that uh Adventure which I'm not going
to finish because it's something that
players should do you're gonna have a
door where you have to put the SE
sequence in low case of uh of what were
the missing notes and it's going to
allow you to come inside the treasure
room where
you will have uh
feedback
uh uh feedback that you can send us and
we will be very happy to have it and
then uh if you have a wallet you will be
able to have a digital asset if not we
will add information to help
uh people to go from Web Two to web 3
and to get those digital
assets and here to be developed would be
future Adventures that I would be very
happy
to
do so this was pretty much the
presentation and hopefully we have play
new players in the coming
days hope you have fun and I really
really encourage anyone to
discover and play with all these ideas
and thoughts and experiments
and things that I have the gut feeling
that are going to revolutionize how we
understand uh the world
and how we can improve in it by reducing
uncertainty so thank you and I don't
know Daniel if you have any comments or
something in this last 10 minutes oh
yeah let's we can definitely talk for a
few minutes I'm I'm seeing many fun
comments and questions in the chat so
people can can post it yeah the game
play is smoother on even a normal
computer Compu it just like it may look
choppy on the live stream but it's quite
a nice um playing experience like maybe
just a little context like how did you
get into building these worlds or what
kind of tools are these and we obviously
don't see them in today's mainstream
educational and research offerings but
like what could that even be to bring
together this kind of
immersion and role play playing with
education
research yes um I as uh um we I I I've
been playing rooll games and rooll games
uh you have uh very uh diverse kind of
players so I I was playing with uh guys
like me like uh
have
um had this struggle through the uh
school and guys that uh end up being uh
researchers like yourself because they
were very good and in those environments
and and and for me it it was like we are
sharing a lot of
cognitive uh um um values and
information and they are really having
fun with me so I the the what what the
Academia is telling me is not is is not
what I'm I'm I'm feeling in in the re in
in outside Academia so that that through
the
years uh it became more and more clear
that was one of uh the drivers to have a
very diverse kind of friends and
and and that one of the most important
things for me to learn it was having fun
and to be a good professional I have to
be enjoying what I'm doing and to enjoy
what I do it has to have that gamify
feeling of it and so in 2021 uh I I I
just went to sty to explore that road uh
because uh block chains what what can do
is have a persistent C of of objects and
attribute attributions to the those
objects and to those wallets that you
can add and build on top of them it's
like having a huge uh database for a
game purpose and and then you figure out
that a game is a kind of organization so
you need rules you need to serve values
you need to uh have like uh what we are
building now which is the cision Sho
which you agree with the players what's
going to be about and how it's going to
work and and we are uh uh building this
um fantastic uh storytelling of how uh
kind of world were it was in the
uh early 20s compared to what's
happening now in this uh imaginary world
that's complementary to what's happening
in real life and we are just exploring
those areas for three years and once I
got into
the into the Institute uh we started
sharing these ideas to uh send us to do
um system thinking curse that it was
super uh cool which uh we we explore and
learn and this uh document that I can
say it was very uh important for us to
understand and we uh find find out the
necessity to be able to Compu what we
are doing so we start focusing more on
ontology on on
on all the the briak breaks that you
need to to understand to build um the
skeleton of uh something that could last
for decades which is uh uh the idea and
we are trying to build it so everyone
can copy paste Fork it and do whatever
they want with the game adapt it to
their own organizations and use it uh on
their favor and and we are just
exploring and having
fun that's that's awesome and there's so
many um there's so many pieces there
it's true about the fun and the
Curiosity those intrinsic
motivations like being six hours deep
into counting ants in the desert or
5,000 pipet pushes deep or whatever it
is in the trenches and in The Last Mile
and
[Music]
um it it can be easy to lose
sight but when we lose sight and when we
put out the fire and the spark it's a
cold dark night and no career or status
or extrinsic valuation is going to
provide like simply the
joy and the the deeper meaning of
like two people going on a little
Adventure running around this space
being inside active inference rather
than active inference being like this
high-speed train that's leaving anyone
behind or you're on the outside and it's
taking these twists and turns and you're
you're getting thrown off it's like it
is cool and air conditioned in this
space and people play and watch a lot of
games where they
wield violent arms and not even like
saying whether that's good or bad it
just it is a genre to want to have a
camera either in a character's head
firstperson perspective or a camera in a
second or a third person perspective
which you can switch between here and
like those kinds of topics about like
egocentric versus allocentric navigation
and our ability to have a a perspective
swap on ourself and be able to take that
kind of like outof
body um situational awareness in real
spatial
settings and just to be able to cruise
through this space and it's like yeah
there's no there's no right way to
Boomerang from ex you could go from
external to sensory you could go here or
there it's it's a um it's an
appetizer and uh a fertilization that
like we've really just never
seen okay yeah thank you very much
Daniel for
this any last thoughts or
comments no just enjoy while we are here
which
is I think our
mission all right thank you Pablo I'm
sure everyone's going to really enjoy
this and let's also of course continue
to um develop these games and continue
to offer these on Rams and have times
where we're meeting up in these spaces
and playing
around thank you cheers bye
farewell all
right